this is a production of Cornell
University
I did up a sabbatical two years ago I
think three years ago forgot already in
New Haven and then we have this big do
you think we can turn the first row of
light please we we have this big a
snowstorm I think after the hurricane
sandy and I spent about three days
trying to get out of my house I did I
did my PhD in florida and i thought i
knew but winters wherever and then I got
to New England Spain one very long long
winter there and then I i sent this
photo sue Camille and Bonnie can they
told me love that happen in Ithaca every
single day for a few Monica so I learned
really that Isle of the tropics that's
what I now you are a plant biologist
pray I don't need to tell you but you're
a geologist the diversity in the
dropping something really amazing so one
hectare in Ecuador has Moses more
species of trees that the entire
continental USA so it's a huge
latitudinal gradient diversity from the
tropics to to temperate latitudes and
and the strike has been in Panama for
almost 100 years last year we
communitarian put 100 years of research
in the tropics because we all there are
very interesting and understanding why
there are so many species in the tropics
and you have to answer that question
from many different point of view
because is not that at a nice equation
come on but first let's say what is a
tropical neotropical rainfall so what
during the next 50 minutes is what I
will define as a as a tropical
rainforest it's a particular combination
of climatic parameters floristic
composition for instructor and
plantation that's what I'm referring to
a new tropical rainforest so a climate
if the mean annual precipitation is
about 1.8 meters a year first rains a
lot the mineral temperature is above 18
degrees Celsius
the floristic see if they if the forest
is dominated abundance and diversity but
certain families plan family life of a
seam or AC and non-ac affiliation also
by the 4 s's trip to the forest is multi
stratified so you have several layers of
the forest and also that the top layer
that is called the canopy is closed and
is dominated by NGO spurred by flowering
plants by closed means that if you get
this photo was taken from a kind of big
crane something we have Australian
Panama is like a capsule that you can go
and see the forest for novel that is
something that is very hard to see from
the ground when you go on and see the
forest for now Rob you realize that
every single spaced in this canopy is
covered with a leaf because most of the
light in the photos is trapped within
the few meters so they trees they really
need to reach the canopy they want to do
a lot of photosynthesis and also plant
physiol ami that the leaves tend to be
really large and they will most of the
leaves have an entire margin so imagine
that is very smooth without edges and
also has a drip tip so when I see these
characteristics is what I will call a
neotropical rainforest now you want to
track a vegetation over time well
probably all your data will come from
continental sequences and having a tool
to be able to date the continental rocks
is very important otherwise you always
be lost in time and you don't have for a
mini frown and a Plantin to do that to
do that we we to solve that problem we
use Pauline ology this is a real example
of a well drilled by a coal and oil
company in Colombia just before I join
this company like 15 years ago just
after I finish my PhD I start working
for this oil company and this is a cross
section of the foothills in Colombia and
this is the world I drift and as you can
see here in the first track that I did
they drill from here to here over our
almost ring
they spend 20 million dollars from here
to here and as you can see the word
parallel to the same bed so they thought
they were going across the strata but
they were really alone the same time
profile because they didn't have a tool
to during the drilling to say well we
are stuck in time we need to change the
direction of the of the drilling bit so
I joined this company and over many
years we use Poland as a tool to solve
this problem and in the tropics
palynology has been used for almost 60
years because a plan evolution is a
fantastic tool to track time over time
so we develop some that is called
biostratigraphic soonish so we went to
many different sites in Colombia
Venezuela and Ecuador and we can't a lot
of pollen grains almost a million pollen
grains so you realized I really low
pollen with so many sides many different
samples and based on all this
information we develop biostratigraphic
so nation that that is basically
hypothesis on plant evolution on when a
particular species originated when that
particular species go extinct and so for
instance this is an example of one of
the of the events in this donation this
is the extension of this particularly
species tell us that we are in sixty 1.9
million years the advantage of working
with oil companies that every time you
do this by ozonation you have your
testing that hypothesis in the next
drilling rig and if you do a mistaken
you tell them that is urs 6560 one and
they end in a different rock you know
right away that your hypothesis was not
correct and you will have to find a new
job it and we develop a method called
maximum we use a maximum likelihood
approach to assess the probability of a
given of assigning a nation to any given
sample so instead of saying all this
rock is late miocene we say we use a pro
little earth and it will tell us the
confidence we are on any given edge for
every particular sample so for reason
this
sample here taking at 400 meters as a
probability of having this age with this
prolific so we are doing that for every
samples we take in our analysis now you
also have to consider climate now this
idea that the tropical of tropical
plants me live very close to the optimal
temperature has been really rooted in
the literature for many years and it's
very easy to understand why you will say
something like that so in this graphic
we have minimal temperature here and
here mean annual precipitation and every
of these dots represent a floristic plot
within the tropical belt and as you can
see here you by changing the
precipitation you can go from a tropical
rainforest here in red to a drive for is
in blue to add a savanna grassland or to
a desert here in green but also you
notice that you don't find almost any
tropical forest no matter what you where
you are about 28 degrees cells so you
may think well that's does they update
the optimal for tropical plants today
however if you search the temperatures
of the tropical land within the tropics
represented here by this red line you
will realize that there is not really a
place within the tropical belt belt that
has a minimal temperature above 28 28
point degree Celsius so perhaps plan
tropical plants cannot live beyond 28
because there are not really many places
in the tropics today without temperature
higher of 28 degree self now if you are
ideologies product you know this have
seen this cure many times and it
represent the proxy for the temperature
of the bottom of the ocean by measure
the Delta o-18 of foraminifera benthic
foraminifera going back from 0 to 120
million years and as you and this is a
very good proxy for global temperature
of the bottom
those that could be correlated to them
ambient temperature of the planet and
when you compared today with most of the
the the last 120 million here who
realized that being in a cold planet is
a very rare compared to most of the day
over the past 200 million years so most
of the time the planet had been much
warmer than today now for years we have
this dichotomy we thought well they have
the tropics are various tape and the
tropics work like a thermostat so no
matter if the global planet is warming
or cooling the temperature in the
tropics will be always a stable so we'll
really something like that or do the
policy environment of cooler but the
tropics are always study and because
it's very stable climate that the reason
we have so many species there now over
the past ten years we have been using
different techniques to assess the
temperature of the tropics during past
level works and as you can see here we
are using plants takes 86 that arise by
biomarker in a molecule in the ocean as
I saw top some from mellifera one of
these techniques for is this the snake
body link of a of a snake we that is
called didn't was reckonin see that we
found in the Cerrejon formation about 60
million years old in the northern part
of Colombia just for comparison this is
a a modern boy of four meters four
meters long so this Titan what was about
45 to 50 feet long about one meter in
diameter and weighed about at home and
was very common in the policing of the
tropical forests of Columbia and today
view if you measure the how loan a snake
is versus where do they live because
they cannot control the in a temperate
internal temperature you will realize
that there's a very good correlation
between the land of the snake and and
the mean annual temperature of a place
and when we apply that to the fossil
record we realized that the tropics were
much warmer before than they are
we did this compilation of all the
empirical data we have on tropical
temperatures for the past 120 million
years about nine five thousand like
6,000 data points across the entire
geological span from 125 to today and
you will see that in the mid-cretaceous
the and this is just for the tropical
belt the temperature the mean annual
temperature what about 7 degrees Celsius
warmer than today during the early
cenozoic in the Basel II during the
early eocene the temperature was about
four point degree Celsius warmer than
today so the graphic in the tropical
belt will be will look like that the
temperature in the trouble has been
warmer than today and probably you
already know that the co2 has been also
much higher than it is now the last time
we have such a low levels of co2 you
will have to go back to the
carboniferous and socio to have been the
constant rather than a high co2 has been
a constant on the planet now let's see
the tropical fossil record now we are
going to divide this the block that
follows in two different settings one
the Cretaceous and other the sinusoid
because the florists in the tropical
there are really fundamentally different
and so I call the Cretaceous and non
angiosperm tropical world we know from
the pollen record that the oldest
angiosperm don't have any geographical
pattern so we find them body high
latitudes mid latitudes and low logic we
still don't know really were they all
the scientists firm the bell dell
latitude a belt that they all decide and
you spend originated one of the oldest
fossils are very tiny blind clans like
alco fructose early fructose from china
now this paper was published about 20
years ago by legal and peter cream and
he compiled all the literature we have
about the only plans within the
Cretaceous and he produced this graphic
that has been used many men
times showing how the angiosperm were
very few at the beginning of the
Cretaceous and by the end of the
Cretaceous the angiosperm dominated the
Flores you can and you see all the data
points he used 14 analysis you will
realize that in the truck this is age
and this is Pena latitude of microflora
sand palkon pollen Flores that most of
the data he used came from temperate
region he they have at this time any any
published locality within the tropics
for the entire Cretaceous and most of
the samples for the polling were done
for biostratigraphy always just focusing
a few markers that were used by your
companies especially in Nigeria and
Brazil now when you look at the
phylogeny some plant botanist they take
all the plans they analyze DNA and
produce this phylogeny that when you
spread the relationship among taxa many
of the file oh geez and the new file
ologies are confirming this that most of
the orders of the angiosperm will evolve
by the cenomanian about 100 million
years 90 to 100 million years ago as as
you can see here now this led us to
publish this paper ten years ago with
chuck davis from university of harbor
saying well we have all these families
and orders backing the mid-cretaceous
therefore you will expect to find a
modern tropical rainforest tropical
rainfall is similar to what we call
today atopica rainforest back in the
mid-cretaceous and we publish this paper
in american naturalist but at this time
i have very little record empirical
record from tropical plants and over the
past in here we have been working very
hard on assessing the record and now i
think we were totally wrong we don't see
it that in the fossil record so we go
back 136 million years and twister
columbia these beautiful flora Collins
and Felix not a single line useful
we move up in time to the apt e an
alvian and still the angiosperm in
abundance are very very very little
about only two percent of the entire
paulina Florida when you do counting's
of the different elements of the Florida
you go into the middle my same onion
with all the phylogeny start saying well
most of the angiosperm are already the
orders are already there and still the
angiosperm represent just a small
percentage of the abundant distribution
of the Flores even more that the
latitudinal gradient in the air
liquidations is either flat or inverted
so when you compare the diversity from
temporary latitude to the tropical to
the tropical latitude that the high
gradient we see today is is not there
now let's move to the end of the
Cretaceous to demonstration so we have
been working on these coal mines in
close to Bogota so the these this guy
goes down in these mines about 300
meters and you can see all the fossil
plants in in the the roof some of the
coal mines and but something very
striking out this Flores that in like
the typical components of the modern
tropical forest has many pounds and many
families of tax hella we don't have any
idea what are they when we compared the
floristic composition of this master ECM
flora with today most common elements
most common families in tropical forests
here represent by these great birds and
in red we have the families we find the
master ischium flora you will see that
the world the this master ECM flora is
not really floristic alee a tropical
rainforest is a forest that lives in the
tropics but is very different from the
forest we have today in the tropics now
you go back you go back to the
cretaceous-tertiary boundary probably
all have hear about this the material
try the Yucatan Peninsula when you look
at the polling record in tropical
latitudes incal
Mia especially we have been working on a
few course one of this is called
diablito where you can with Poland you
can get to a very fine a stratigraphic
resolution and you look at the polling
the diversity of the Poland like going
from 70 million 262 million you see we
saw a big sharp decrease in that in the
diversity and about 75% of all the
species that were in the mass tradition
go extinct and this level is also
represented from the mental change in
the abundant distribution of the Florida
we went from a Florida where only fifty
percent were done useful to observe that
is already fully dominated by
angiosperms in the paleocene not only
that but when you look at the abundance
solution of the seeds and fruit you will
see that in the mastery samsara all
these fruits or seeds are very tiny
while in the in the paleo sing you have
a wide distribution from the small seed
to big seeds or fruit that you can see
here so i think this this event Victor
stairs here the cretaceous-tertiary when
changed fundamentally the structure and
composition of the tropical rainforest
we went from the forest where the canopy
probably was open and dominated by jingo
sperms I love carriers probably to the
canopy closed canopy dominated by useful
we know today we can look also at the
venation density in the fossil lips so
these are 12 subs of fossil lives and as
you can see we can see the very fine
venation of the of the least back in the
paleocene or the mass Tristian now you
go today to a rainforest and you measure
the venation density of all the leaves
from the bottom of the forest to the top
of the forest you will see that there is
a strong bimodal distribution so in the
canopy you have a very high venation
density and in the understory you have
low venation density and it's prolly you
and you could explain that because
whether you are here in the canopy you
want to maximize the amount of
photosynthesis you want to do because
you are exposure to the light
and if you are in the in the lower level
with the light is very diminished you
don't spend so much energy having a lot
of bang because you cannot do a lot of
photosynthesis but you you can see that
this closed canopy will give you this
bimodal distribution of the forest today
and you see that in the leader so you go
underneath the forest and you collect
the leaves in the litter you will see
the same bimodal distribution that you
see represented in the forest today we
compare the divination density of many
different Flores within the tropics and
temperate latitudes front from the
Oblivion to the paleocene as you can see
here and only until the paleocene we see
this bimodal distribution that this
typical of modern tropical rainforests
represented here in black compared to
all the different distribution we see
during the Cretaceous within this and
evidence that not only the forest
composition change but also the
structure of the forest itself change as
well now this change I think not only
affected the forest itself but also the
climate project I think Camilla toreador
Kevin boys came here a few months ago to
give a seminar and Kevin did this
beautiful study work he did a climatic
modeling of the Amazonia but instead of
having annual span he put gymnosperms
and because the gymnosperm have a very
low variation density at the leaves are
smaller they were both transpiration the
photosynthesis they do is lower than the
Angels so he run this climatic modeling
and the result were really struggling so
just by changing the forest for energy
and you spend to gino's burn the
temperature represented here by the
precipitation represented here by the
blue of the genius / loaded by the
yellow the genius for the precipitation
drop by thirty-five percent and the
temperature increased by three degree
celsius and the lane of the dry season
increased by 2 mode so having a
gymnosperm Forester make the tropics
warmer and and dryer
just because the effect of the
transportation of the Leafs had on the
on the climate itself about half of the
rainfall that happened in tropic today
comes from the transportation of the
plants themselves so the lessons I think
we can learn from the Cretaceous that
but the end of the Cretaceous then just
felt like diamonds bio bio mass
dominance I did not rule most of the
landscape in the tropics even though
they were diversifying it doesn't
transfer that into ecological dominance
but probably there were a lot of shrubs
and herbaceous and mostly come in
floodplains understood the habitats and
I think it's a fantastic example how
morphologic an innovation all these
characteristics that make an anticipated
an angiosperm lacks ecological success
but at least 55 million years and also
that the change in landscape of
competency lead to a change in tropical
climate now let's go to the second
chapter are they the entire cenozoic
where we see a canopy that is already
dominated by a distance and I'm sure you
going to show you one of the oldest
tropical rainforests as i define it that
we know today and it's from Cerrejon
just to keep in mind the throne is
within the precipitation rate of modern
tropical rain forests but the
temperature was about a degree and a
half warmer that any tropical rainforest
today and that's how we think that the
this rain forest look like with the
giant snakes and huge massive crocodiles
and big turtles we have been studying
this in the in the Cerrejon coal mine
this is the biggest open pit coal mine
in the world every year they removed the
same amount of material that was removed
to construct the Panama Canal and they
the mine has been operated for almost 35
years it proves about 3 million tons of
coal per year just to give you a sense
of the size of this mind there are about
seven pits like this one
and this this here this tiny dot here is
one of these if you have been a coal
mine one of these huge trucks that are
that people in the mind industry use
that so it allow us an amazing
opportunity to to look for fossils those
just a collage of many the typical
plants we find in in the Cerrejon we
have legumes many other fossils now as
we did with the maastrichtian when you
compare the Cerrejon the paleocene and
in red the family we find in the fossil
record there with the modern families
that you see that floristic elisa reckon
is already know tropical rainforest as i
told you we have this not only the
forest if biomass was very large but
also only the animal seems to be really
huge we did at this model of tita know
what this is my son you see has a very
long hair and i haven't been able to hit
for him to cut the hair because he said
I want yellow that yes so this model has
been traveling for the past two years
now as i miss you ninny i think it in
what seattle and d that was done by an
artist in canada so that the Cerrejon
also show us that the families that
dominate the rainforest in the Taliesin
are they still dominated the external
tropical rainforest now you move from
the palace in upington you will find
this called the pity and the
paleocene-eocene thermal maximum this is
a unique interval in our history of
people had been study all over the world
for many years because it's probably the
closest analog to the warming we are
having today the temperature went up by
five to seven degrees Celsius in 10,000
years that even though probably the
fastest in the geological record is
about ten time is lowered to what is
happening nowadays
when when you see all the climate models
that have been done to be able to
reproduce the PPM the only way to reach
the temperature of high latitudes to the
empirical levels that we know happened
during the ptn is pumping a lot of co2
in the atmosphere so in this particular
model harbor and Caballero they they had
to go to 4,500 PPM's of co2 remember
today we're in 402 ppm that's the only
way you can reach the temperature that
we find in the high latitudes but when
that happens you see here in the South
America they they propose that you just
have a dead zone in the tropics because
the temperature will reach beyond 45
degrees Celsius of mean an old temple so
he means that during middle of the day
the temperature can go up to 90 degree
Celsius so we have been now because the
PTM is only 10,000 years is the
beginning and the warming and then 190
thousand years for the cooling for the
whole interval is andreea it's only 200
thousand years and in rock that could be
represented by only one metre not two
meters depending on sedimentation rate
so we spend many many years almost 50
years I I look for many different
sections all over Colombia and Venezuela
and finally we find three sites where we
were absolutely sure that the PTM was
located one of those we have to go with
a helicopter and the Colombian Army look
like skeet geology so much that they
went with us to collect this particular
size and this is those are the three
sites and here this bar represent this
block represent the ppm and in green are
the taxa that are present in both and
this is pollen in the three panels and
as you can see we we found the opposite
to what we expected we were expecting a
high levels of extinction the
the ppm and very low levels of
origination and what we saw was just the
opposite that they there is a huge a
spike in the origination rate in the ppm
and the levels of extinction are very
low so when we calculate the per capita
or the national extinction rate we see
that during the PTM the origination went
up not an highest in earnest we we
anticipated now when you look at the
many different phylogeny of different
plant groups like the orchids or
epiphytic firms even the original form
of our heart agriculture but this is
very tricky on the date in itself but
many of them seems to show that during
the earlier seen something is really
happy now that also begged the question
that probably this Clyde Clyde climate
model is not correct because we'd be
very hard to us to explain how can a
plant live at a mean annual temperature
50 degrees Celsius that's almost as the
physical limit of many of those plans so
it means that that we don't have a very
good way to reproduce the climate do
during Lowell world there's something
missing the climate system that we don't
understand that is amplifying that
Worman in the poles while maintaining
but by and also increases the
temperature in the pot in the equator
but not at a high degree as we see that
in the post is something something
really missing them but have the co2
sensitivity is larger than 3 degree
Celsius that we have been assuming for a
long long time now we continue up in
time you will see during the entire tell
you seen your sin or legacy neomycin and
this is once again the temperature of
the bottom of the ocean and if you move
in this direction as one when you move
in the direction
school and this is the plan diversity of
the Northern neotropics look through the
pollen record and as you can see there
is a good correlation between the
long-term trends in warming and
increasing diversity and the long-term
trends in cooling and the drop in
diversity and we see that happen in a
very short time scale like the PTM and a
long time scale during the Cenozoic now
it seems like every few weeks there is a
new paper in National Science
anticipated the collapse of all the
ecosystems in the tropics because of the
current global warming and well there
are many bad things that happen to plans
when you increase the temperature so the
net production decreased due to
increased respiration the photosynthesis
slow down yeah many bad things a lot of
leaf a stress so how come this we are
ticipate that the plant will not
function very well the temperature is
very high but the fossil record show the
opposite well during the temperature of
the leaf is controlled mostly by the
temperature of the earth the co2 and the
moisture in the soil is not only
temperature and now we will go back to
the paleocene for isn't we always see
high levels of co2 I high levels of
rainfall we can assess rainfall by
looking at the leaf area the bigger the
area of the fossil leaves the bigger the
precipitation and so we can assess the
precipitation of a given flora in this
case the Cerrejon was 3.5 3.4 meters of
rainfall and there are many experiments
have shown that the temporal the
photosynthesis of the planning the plan
can do a better photosynthesis at a
higher temperature when the co2 are
hydrated especially if the precipitation
and elevate the negative effect of the
warming in this experiment we do with
the clouds winton ecophysiology at the
strike when we put all these plants in
enclosure with the co2 was double of the
amount
we have today and here the black is the
experiment with the LMA co2 and great is
the experiment with the co2 week we have
today in all of the cases the planet
plan water use efficiency increases at
the co2 goes up and this is your the
proportion of the water that the plan
uses versus the proportion of the water
that the plan losses in the
photosynthesis eve and
evapotranspiration so it means that when
you have a lot of co2 the plant don't
need to use as much water at they used
before and perhaps even though the
temperature goes up as the co2 goes up
they don't need to be exposed to the
high temperature as today now also when
you increase the temperature you may
think well perhaps at the temperature
expand toward the temperate latitudes
the tropical rainforest here represented
here in this green color we expand our
higher latitudes if you do that for the
eocene and you use the temperature
gradient we have today and the
temperature gradient we have in the
paleocene you will see by that by
increasing the temperature during the
earlier sing warning you will find 18
degrees Celsius so the temperature right
I told you was the boundary lower
boundaries tropical rainforests you will
find that temperature down in Patagonia
in both cases so you will expect for the
tropical rainforests to expand to our
tropical latitudes now these are many
hypotheses on biome evolution during the
early using the green the rainforest and
as you see many people has predicted
that the room forest will expand to add
Patagonia high latitudes other side now
perhaps you will have a varied rice area
during this sinusoid warming we did the
analysis of comparing many of the fossil
record we have here with many of the
fossil record in Chile and Arjun
and we realized that the tropics done
Drake the tropical rainforest don't
expand to at high latitudes during
global warming's what we see is the
development of a of a new biome that the
paleontologist in Argentina called they
mix paleo Florida Romero and Romero
publish this about 19 in 1978 and he
already gave us the answer 40 years ago
that really the tropics don't expand to
wear to wear high latitudes during
global warming but what you see is the
evolution of a new biome adapted to
temperate areas during winter that are
not so cold and you see a very
distinctive abundant distribution the
most important families between the
fossil record of the neotropics in the
eocene versus the lower latitudes in
South America during the using so in
this sinusoidal record show us that the
temperature correlates with the
diversity alone and short time scale
that prolly tropical fan plant families
already have the genetic variability to
cope with high temperature to the high
co2 and there is a strong niche
conservative the trouble as I happen to
me living in New England for doing the
winter you there we'd only that you are
living in the tropics very hard to move
to high latitudes and pronator the co2
climate sensitivity is larger than three
degrees Celsius now i'm going to show
you the last chapter of this story and
is the bird of a new ecosystem this
awareness in orange is the solution of
modern Savannah's today and we really
depend on Savannah and most of our Greek
culture and most of the people live in
Savannah's because it's much easier to
live in a savannah but in a place where
is raining all the time and you can
explain why we have dry sounds today
just by the atmospheric circulation of
our planet you will always find dry sons
in the subtropics because of the
the difference along the bit with the
equator and high latitudes and indeed
many people as i showed you before has
has shown that they were savannas of
grasslands back in time like in the
earliest however when you look at the
plant phylogeny for many of the most
important families that live in
Savannah's or seraphic dick environments
today you will see that muscle then
indeed shorty Nations backing tank but
the actual radiation happen within the
last ten million years so that's very
interesting why you will expect to find
always drives on back in time why you
only see this big radiation happening
within the last ten million years now we
have been stunned empirical record of
this dry areas over the past few years
one of this is called castigated here in
northern part of Colombia that today is
basically a desert beautiful place we
have been collecting there for many
years this is Camila Martinez here
collecting years ago beautiful place
close to you sometimes you will see this
huge sandals and there is a massive
called Emek we're a mountain that is in
the middle of the desert with cloud
forest and rain forest as the Sun an
island among this big big desert and in
the desert itself we find a lot of
fossils like this this is the this
column for Gabriel oh this a strap
Italian deserve this the task of this
animal that looks like a like a kind of
a hypo potent but from South American
origin once you clean the puzzle that
will look like sometimes you have
Gabrielle's like this is cold and
remember they are coming from this very
dry desert today many species of pudding
souders is one of the biggest crocodile
that ever existed i was very common all
over the neotropics this animal couldn't
fit in this room and was very common in
we were here at that time you find this
lot of Diana man Ilyas capybaras this
very large freshwater turtles like the
stupid Davis see the size of this guy so
you can get a sense of the size of this
freshwater turtle related to the
sharpest do they live in the early knock
but they're about the size or you'll
find this giant guinea pig now about 700
kilos two meter tall they are very
productive ecosystem so this is how we
think the cast yet is look three million
years ago permanent rivers a lot of
biomass and this is how cassia this
looks today we also went looking into
the Yanis of Columbia the savannas and
you haven't been in the savannas it's an
amazing beautiful place you see all
these grasslands and you only see trees
along the water cause worries now this
applies difficult to study because there
are no out groups but an oil company
drill a core one of these places and we
were able to study the entire core and
this is the pollen record of the grasses
and this is the geological time going
from 23 million years to today and as
you can see even over the up to 75
million years you don't see any evidence
of brasland in the ya nose of columbia
today so prairie the savannas also
evolves or expand during the last three
or four million years now if you think
about the expansion of all these
drylands here and also all the cerrado
this is a an area that used to be
occupied by tropical rainforest now
today we know that there is a very good
relationship between area and i'm the
number of a species the larger the area
the number they hire the number of a
species so if you do the opposite so
instead of increase in the area you
decrease the area or neck of an
ecosystem well i will predict largest
engine
across many different plates so I think
if you look at the phylogeny of many
plant families today in the in Amazonia
they must be a significant reduction in
diversity over the past 5 million years
that probably because in the DNA if you
look up phylogeny is very hard to do to
look at a phylogeny something doesn't
exist today so prolly there's a
fundamental buyers in the way we
analyzed phylogenetic data to assess the
past diversity that we don't understand
very well but I respect that the
diversity in their Messiah has dropped
over the past 5 million years now I
always thought that the pliocene was
really boring that nothing really
happened there but over the last year's
I realized how really critical they meet
pliocene was and really changed the
climate the state of our planet so you
look at the temporal record from 60
million years to today you see that
around three to two point seven you see
a fundamental change in the this term of
very warm climate what we see today this
oscillation of warming and cooling
during day since the glaciation start
2.7 million years ago and also that the
co2 has been changing over time at least
during the last interglacial we have
been going from 180 parts per million to
280 parts per million and we are in 402
parts per million so you could summarize
this climate state what we are now today
is a conjunction of fourth factor that
we have not seen at least for 400
million years the first one is that we
have very steep latitudinal temperate
gradient from the equator to the poles
that today is about 50 degrees Celsius
so you go from 27 Celsius in the tropics
to minus minus 20 in the polls you go
back to the using it was 32 to 14 so the
increase in the temporary
gradient is the strongest we have seen
in a long time the second point is that
we have a strong temperature gradient
between the eastern Pacific and the
western Pacific that's something we
haven't had in a very very long time the
difference in temperature from the sea
here in France Australia to the
temperature of the ocean here in front
of a quarter the third the first time we
have ice in the polls permanent ice in
both Paul and the first time in a long
long time that the co2 has dropped below
200 parts per million and today not a
single climatic model has been able to
have these four elements in their
modeling to reproduce of the climate of
the hell applies so there is something
is still missing out about the climate
now we know that what controls a very
large degree the different ecosystem
within the tropic is not really the
temperature but precipitation how the
amount of rainfall and the lane of the
dry seas and you can see that very easy
if you go to waheeda this is during
lenia event in 2011 when a lot of
precipitation was brought here to the
northern part of columbia and this is a
linear when precipitation drops and this
is our changes that happen within three
or four months and green is the
vegetation you see how you go for a
really desert to very low grassland only
by changing the precipitation within a
single deal now with in the tropics what
controls most of the precipitation
resent the Intertropical Convergence
zone so this low humidity ratio belt
that is moving all the time along the
year so when you have winter in the
southern the IPCC is always moving away
from the from the hemisphere that is the
coldest so during the winter in the
Northern in the southern hemisphere the
IPCC move north and during the winter in
North America the IPCC
moves out so if you are here for instant
you will always have rain because the
bell goes up and up but if you are here
for instance during the during the
winter here you will get the rain during
the winter here you get the dry season
and that's what brings the rain now but
that works when you have ice in both
polls we still don't know what happened
very well if the ice is only one pole
and then south in the north we don't
have eyes in any of the poles we don't
know if for the sign of you we don't
have eyes here or here it ain't I TCC
get wider and doesn't move very much or
the precipitation increase all along the
way with very very few empirical data
about precipitation that is really like
the key factor here rather than
temperature so final conclusion of these
large chapter is that is this is another
example of how morphological innovation
the fact of job in a grass like
ecological success by 3 million years so
we see all these legion lineages of
albany back in the using but you only
see large diversification and the köppen
CEO of landscape within the last 10
million years we also predict a large
deduction and tropical forest coverage
and also that model most climate models
failed to predict the lack of extensive
Savannah's during global warming
intervals and I think just to summarize
well everything I told you we present
this movie of the biomes over the past 5
55 million years so each color
represents a particular biome and we
have been using G plate to to assess the
volumes so we'll study 55 million years
I will end today
so in green forest in the black here the
tropical rain forest from the the table
in North American latitudes it went very
fast now yeah just twin sometimes people
you see that the funding for geological
science has been dropping at least an
NSF in Colombia and many places in the
world but when you realize that over the
past 150 years we went from 280 parts
per million to four hundred and two
parts per million and if you go back to
the last glaciation 20,000 years ago we
went from 81 82 to 80 so I only a
hundred parts per million in 20,000
years here we have been going up about
130 parts per million in only 150 years
and that 402 is very close to the levels
of co2 back in the pliocene so the last
time we have a co2 like we have it today
you have to go back five million years
you realize that we are really in a
massive global experiment to reproduce a
climate of the past I'm probably geology
and I think what we do it the
paleoclimate the requested germ and
ancienne ecosystem is really critical to
understand and predict what is going to
happen because all the historical
records that people is using to build
climatic model so the experiments are
based on historical records and none of
the historical records human had by
looking at the temperature precipitation
over the past 200 years has had levels
of co2 similar to what we have today you
really have to go back to the geological
record to reproduce bodies will be
happening and is already happening over
the next decades to come just to give
you a sense of that this is an
experiment it has been running from my
building and so we have these two
greenhouses and in this greenhouse we
have the co2 us today so the ambien
this is 402 far spent minute in this one
and here we are trying to replicate 280
parts per million so the co2 we have a
hundred and fifty million years ago and
had been a lot of work so we have here a
very large column full with calcium
carbonate and we have a sensor of co2
here and every time the co2 goes about
280 we stop there between this capsule
and they co2 combined with the carbonate
and that drops down the co2 and what we
heard here is corn zea mays and we are
assessing the the how fast the cmas the
corn can grow and defend co2 condition
and you already see how the co2 the corn
in the high co2 in the co2 of today is
growing really really fast compared to
the co 250 years ago but we are spending
a lot of funding just to replicate how
the climate was 150 years ago this is
just incredible and I think that models
the clues is going to the Filner today
study a fossil record of the tropics
that is mostly unexplored and sometimes
you find like these big trees at 4,000
meters of elevation in the Altiplano in
the Peruvian Andes thank you very much
for your attention
I was struck by the comparison of the
models of the paleocene-eocene climate
maximum that were seeking these 45 to 50
degrees centigrade and you compare you
with with what you saw in fossil record
is it is there a way for you to actually
to calibrate those models by telling
people how hot it really was and be wise
from the fossil record yeah we have been
pre-cut imaging we have our duty to the
desert but they just compound the
problem because you have to reach the
temperature of live I was close to the
call to 14 degrees Celsius without
increasing the temperature in the drums
you need to be research and that's
impossible and no matter what
combination you to walk in ocean charger
yeah this a fundamental component of the
planet that neither understand the
reason we are not able to replicate but
we don't replicate even the early
pliocene plan that is just as more
example of the climate back in the early
so we have a long way to go and when you
see all the predictions we do for the
future they are based on on the
historical record money and we have this
co2 we are they about that you just
don't know they also made many models
have predicted that around 400
there is an you could have a climate
estate change some research you can turn
for us a bad name to a break forth into
account report because of the scene 2 is
much higher but is not a great web
driver change for a dress code change so
you have one system and then you have
the nexus the change is really pretty
fast and we are approaching to that I
hope before I like by ac-12 450f I was
looking forward
so the reason that we would have the
savanna climate climate change was cold
biologically the real
press into because climate change or are
you saying that from no I he did duty
first need to change the climate by
increased LM of the crisis so you expand
the man who escaped and then the glasses
regret the area's increase if you have a
hybrid news but the grasses have been
there for a long time yes April is
displayed their absence of extensive
survivors but my dream they are using
window you have this broker situation
why they don't have extensive
surveillance back into possible is a
possible with the type of transpiration
faster turnover participation rank of a
brain
each trophic school in the key is see
this one sorry boys the class has
experiments of fighters growing at 45
degrees Celsius but if you put enough
water the plants okay but this second
floor experience disappointed as much
when someone over plants but actually
increase increase in Bible he flies in
the face of displays change yeah listen
the ppm we see we think that they
biomass increase and we not see an
increasingly we're moving the water in
water use efficiency so that's it that
extra water that the plan is not music
it could be used to lose more by one so
go back to the atmosphere from drugs and
perhaps depending of it animation of the
cloud you can go from cooling to war
with each other very treatable it could
be another factor that is is learning
the Probie school while the whole plan
is for you but I still the different is
so there's a large degree of paper you
have to raise the temperature in the
poll but at the same time maintaining
the temperature for teachers
five itself and the other is
the historical state
over those taxa still extant and
restricted
expand again similar
or they all instinct in we need to start
over
Thanks you know i need you're going to
cheat away those are the remedies of
these mix of unitary state yeah because
they don't have a favorite area you see
possibility for privacy
and culturally
my name's
yeah that's before staying you don't
worry reason is you then one of forest
colleges have been increasing my crazy
I've been living in powerful statement
that is this freedom ten years ago to
the only two hours of comparison and the
whole thing will be covered with and you
go today and he's just want to cry the
most of the forest is gone so there is
not really this great effect of about
expedition into the forest is not there
anymore i want to receive bonito few
years they have this meeting this is the
Pantanal period of course but used to be
afforded to go there because the soy
price has been going up because of our
people and also this stencil area that
used to be despondent of course you are
converted into saw you so kill that you
can you cannot see the enemy shoes and
they are transformed what happened
within the last eight years so investor
from all over the world to fund his
hedge funds have been buying till sorry
for the landscaper Arreaga that is just
unbearable so all this cool electric is
we know
but you have the things a sealed room
yep so it would seem that he has it but
the only mechanism you have if you know
pretty high co2 to keep the traffic
school it just have a pretty permanent
cloud cover and yeah I don't ya do you
have any panty medicator 444 light level
it might tell you that you know the if
you really had a permanent sort of cloud
cover that you could pick out some way I
don't know if there's any physiological
characteristics that is related to that
and the canopy leaves right obviously
the other storage i was going to be dark
but is it can you see anything the
canopy that might say he's it wasn't as
many photons well doesn't that mean that
they open it was immediately we happen
they thinking about that for a few years
now and we still having planet funk
seafood to measure but i love to do that
yeah we have taken for Easter exploring
that they tell you in the cubicles of
the least but the signals yeah we still
need to go over and we got bored to the
forest today under some relationship
leaves and the cough corner because the
clouds we don't have any data encoded
with us today yeah basically in previous
a morning person so they're pretty
speciation outpaced extension through
pneumatically this would happen network
which you can't predict the same ratio
human own little bit the president is
key of the changing to hear me sing we
increased 150 years whether to ground
and over the past twenty thousand year
we will increase this year to have a
first communion so the braids are so we
never had such an incredible rate that
is very hard to tell whether populations
I'm going to the spaghetti with high
levels of before state so yeah I would
have predicted the in a typical model is
visible wrong but at the end cover
species on the hundred forty thousand
years and the fossil record we know that
any given species on areas are streaming
kiara very small and even big animals
so we have here
in a production of Cornell University on
the web at cornell edu